100 degrees celsius dang and the fan is
still off apple what are you doing does
the m2 macbook pro overheat and throttle
well we are going to find out because
apple raised the power in this laptop
while using the same design we're gonna
be doing tests that nobody else has done
we're gonna look at the temperatures the
fan noise the frequencies if it slows
itself down and see how the m2 chip
performs now some people are
disappointed and they're saying that
this is a recycled machine and i'm not
talking about the aluminum i'm talking
about apple taking the same machine not
changing anything and selling it to
people if we look at this the actual
wallpaper is identical to the one that
came out closer to what year and a half
ago or so and even on the back here this
sticker is covering up something behind
it and people posted where it's
literally an m1 box with a sticker on
top of it now i guess it's good that
they're recycling but the other hand
you're not really getting a completely
new machine it's literally just made to
maximize profit so since everything is
the same even the charger doesn't
support fast charging we are going to
open this thing up and get right into
seeing how this m2 chip performs all
right guys we are all set up and we have
to download a bunch of different
programs to get the detailed sensor data
fan data to be able to show you guys so
we have a couple apps right here and one
interesting thing is
look at this fan speed i don't remember
the m1 macbook pro going up to 7
200 rpm
it's gonna be interesting to hear how
these fans work and how loud they get
when we run our rendering tests let's
start out with a super quick geekbench
and right here we see the apple m2 chip
at 3.48 gigahertz that is nearing 10
higher clock speeds compared to m1 here
are the results we have a single core
score of 1905
now we have seen up to 1930 online but
even this score is the fastest single
core in any laptop now the multi-core is
at 88.53
definitely not the fastest but it's a
good score and a decent jump now we also
have our laptop plugged in we're getting
it charged up all the way because the
next video we're going to shoot is going
to be the comparison to the m1 macbook
pro we're going to see how the
performance compares we're also going to
take off the bottom covers and compare
the fans and the internals did apple put
in a better fan we will see so make sure
you guys are subscribed down below now
as far as the metal graphics test wow
that is actually an incredible score
higher than what i've seen 30 842 this
is much closer to the 2 000
m1 pro macbook than it is to the m1
that's a nice score we'll see how that
does in the real world now those were
the easy tests this is where it's going
to get difficult now before i start i'm
going to get out my thermal cam let's
see how hot this thing is just sitting
here running those simple tests 30
degrees celsius at that hottest point
all right guys check this out i just
hovered over the m2 chip and it is
saying that the single core is at 3.5
but it's estimating that the multi-core
will run slower at 3.2 now the m1 chip
it ran the same frequency no matter what
so we'll have to see what it actually
runs at let's start out with a single
core test here we'll see how this runs
how much power uses we have this awesome
program pseudoacetop command line tool
that gives us so much awesome detail and
then our fan monitor down below so we're
around halfway done and we found another
interesting thing we're only getting
just above 3.3 gigahertz instead of 3.5
now this is stuff that you'll only find
on max deck now that's either because
the program is under utilizing it or
maybe you only get 3.5 if you're not
maxing out that single core cpu which we
can find out in just a second so apple
might be doing things that intel have
been doing all right so our average
wattage was just over 5 watts that means
if all the cores are running at that
power level we'd be at over 20 watts
instead of 15. our score is 1582.
i'm double checking geekbench here and
we're still only hitting at 3.3
gigahertz for the single core light test
so is 3.5
not true at all when can we actually use
that and now let's max out the cpu now
i'm not going to run the 10 minute test
i'm going gonna run individually one at
a time so we can see how much throttling
we get if we get any now right off the
bat our cpu is maxed out and look at
this we are limited to 33
200 megahertz 3.2 we are not getting any
higher it is just capped it's not even
bouncing around like it did with the
single core it is just sit literally
sitting there so apple is limiting it to
that frequency even if it's running cool
now we're already at 88 degrees celsius
right now
93.95 and the fans are still off 97
degrees celsius 98 the fan is still off
99. is this a macbook air where is our
fan
100 degrees celsius
dang and the fan is still off apple what
are you doing 101 degrees celsius
okay
here we go
we have fans 1 500 rpm vadim yeah that's
it 1500 rpm our first one just finished
it's
8546 that is pretty low so maybe it was
slowing down because of how hot 102
degrees celsius now okay the fans are
starting to spin yeah this is a dang hot
machine that's silent
if you want that for now but wow apple
is waiting a long time 101 still our fan
is almost half speed now how are we at
100 degrees celsius guys
if you don't want your system to turn
this hot get tg fan pro uh i'll put a
link in the description you can set your
own fan curves exactly how you wanted to
limit the temperature to make your
system last a long time our second run
is 8592
that is also low but actually higher
than the first run because apple is not
ramping up the fans at all now this
program uh that reads uh all of our
information it does use some power so
it'd be good to do a run without it
because it's taking all the data in but
still
that is not great now our peak wattage
was 24 watts our average is currently
about 19 and a half but as it's slowing
down and getting hot we're at 101
degrees celsius right now that average
kind of goes down now the fan is still
at 3 700 instead of 7
200. so it's still
barely spinning even though we're at
these high temps and now we have 85 62
so ashley went down a bit we're at 102
degrees celsius we've been at over 100
for i don't know closer to 10 minutes
now our fans are slowly creeping up
we're at 4 300 now
4 400 so maybe now after 10 minutes
it wants to run the fans faster because
these temps are high we did not see such
high fan tabs with the m1 chip and as
you guys see we are using more wattage
this time even though it's still running
at 3.2 gigahertz and as we're running
those tests take a look we're running at
40 degrees celsius now still not too bad
the hottest spot has changed now to
right there i'm guessing where the m2
chip is so our first run was the worst
and even the fifth run the fans were
only about halfway up there so what if i
max out the fans myself and see what
this thing is capable of now some people
are saying that the fan on this thing is
extremely loud i mean i hear it it's
definitely not quiet but there's a lot
of windows laptops out there that are
way louder so in tomorrow's video we'll
see how the fans compare with the m1 mac
pro and we'll also run cinebench without
the power metrics to see the max
performance but now we max out the fan
let's see what score we get and how hot
the chip gets if the fan is maxed out so
we are almost done here and we are at 87
degrees it actually stopped at about 80
45 it's basically very slowly going up
compared to i think we peaked at 104
before so that's a huge difference and
we got
85.92
that's actually uh the same score as we
got on our second run so the performance
is not getting much better keep in mind
the scores would be higher if we didn't
have this program open but with that
said the temps are much lower and now
let's test out the graphics we're going
to max them out with 3dmark's wildlife
extreme see how much power it's drawing
compared to the m1 and what the
temperatures look like all right so it
looks like a graphics is using just over
12 watts we peaked at 12.35 12.45 right
there but we're not seeing 15 watts like
apple showed off on stage and with that
we're still running fairly cool and our
fan is off now unfortunately we don't
actually have an active sensor that's
usable yet for the graphics hopefully
that gets fixed soon but typically the
cpu goes up with the gpu because it's on
the same chip with the same cooler now
here is our score we have 40.8
fps so that means that it is 35 faster
than the m1 which is exactly what apple
said on stage but with that the m1 pro
and the 2000 macbook pro that is 38
faster than the m2 so the m2 is closer
to the m1 than the m1 pro at least with
a 100
gpu load and as we showed you guys it's
still running at about 12 watts not 15
so i wonder in what cases do we actually
get that 3.5 gigahertz and we get
the full 15 watts of gpu power i guess
we will have to see in our other
comparisons running real world tasks and
maybe mixing up cp and gpu usage now the
last thing i want to run here is the
stress test we'll see if we get any
throttling with the gpu now this is a 20
minute test and i left it alone for a
little bit and i come back we're on loop
9 out of 20
and we're actually at 90 degrees celsius
right now on the cpu
now now we're at 91 with the fans
running at 3000 rpm meaning that the gpu
is even hotter there's a good chance
that could be over 100 degrees as well
but apple likes to keep their fan speeds
low so even though the gpu doesn't use
as much power like we saw it is still
getting toasty alright guys we are
finished and look at that at the start
we actually have worse performance right
here for the first three to four runs
that's because apple is not kicking up
the fans and then once it does we
actually jump up to performance up to
6920
and then when i showed you guys around 9
and 10 run ten dropped down to six
thousand seven hundred and nineteen and
then it kind of stayed lower because the
whole system is heat soaked and it's
pretty hot even with the fans running
louder so this proves that yes the m2
macbook pro does throttle and a big part
of that is not only the heat soak but
apple just not activating the fans
instead they're giving you worse
performance so i have to say that i am a
bit disappointed not only because we
never really saw the 3.5 gigahertz but
that the wattage isn't what apple showed
off on stage and the fact that this
thing gets so hot we saw 104 degrees
celsius they're not kicking up the fans
when they should be so not only do they
not redesign this and we don't have mag
safe or we don't have a better webcam
but the fact that m2 chip is more like
an m 1.5 chip based on previous videos
we've done talking about that in reality
that really is what we're getting now we
are going to compare it to the m1
macbook pro we will do a battery life
comparison as well to see how it stacks
up we're going to take that bottom cover
off and look at the fans internally so
make sure you guys click that subscribe
button above so you guys don't miss out
that video check out one of those great
ones right over there that's been max
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]